what kind of levers does the speaker
have in relation to the other house
representatives the speaker has all
kinds of levers both formal and informal
in fact a lot of them are informal so
the speaker can speaker names a lot of
people to the committee to the
committee's particularly to the quote
the Rules Committee in the house and
what does the Rules Committee to the
Rules Committee sets the rules for
what's debated and what comes onto the
floor and so through controlling the
Rules Committee you can control what
kinds of amendments come up how much
debate there is for unpopular ideas and
you can help get legislation through by
managing the rules under which it's
debated there's a famous instance in
which Dennis Hastert who is Speaker of
the House under george w bush held open
a vote on Medicare Part D this was
adding prescription drugs to the
Medicare plan and we're holding open a
vote means as you said a certain time
for the number of votes that come in and
at the end of that time you count the
votes are they in does it pass well it
wasn't passing and so Hastert let the
votes stay open while he went around and
strong-armed individual members of the
Republican side he was a Republican
Speaker strong-armed them said you
really got a vote for this and finally
got enough votes and just when it went
over the threshold boom he closed the
window said the votes over and it passed
and what did he do to get those extra
votes well you can give people plum
committee assignments you can help their
legislation get to the floor that maybe
wasn't getting there fast enough and the
other powers you have is you can go
raise money for them or get the people
you know on the political side to make
their run for re-election
easier so there are lots of gifts you
can give to your members or things you
can withhold from them to make them do
what you want